Next up, let's talk about how we communicate between UMG and materials.
So we want to go back into our widget display from a previous class.
We want to open the right menu display widget and we'll be upgrading these new icons here.
So this is what you'll probably see on the right display menu from a previous tutorial
where we've had the temperature, airspeed, car speed and light.
All we want to do is add a horizontal box to the bottom, add the text, which is something along the lines of the current temperature to 72 degrees,
and then the image, which is the temp image.
And then when we want, we change the brush to an image as you've done previously,
and set the hot and cold material instance, which we created at the start of the tutorial here.
So you can tweak those visuals to whatever you'd like.
The visuals don't so much matter as much as the actual functionality.
Of course, the visuals are important for the user experience.
But for today's functionality and purposes, we'll talk about blueprinting.
So these are the three sections that we're going to be creating.
So again, we'll jump into the editor to show you exactly what's going on here.
But based on the previous variable creation, you should get a pretty good feel about what we're going to be doing here.
So we've got three sections, which is the pre construct.
We've got the air slider and we've got the temp slider.
We will create two functions called update text and update image.
And then we'll use three variables, which is the UI, the airspeed flow, and then also the display reference, which is the vehicle blueprint.
So let's jump in and break those down for you.
So in our editor, let's create all of our variables that we'll need.
So we'll go to create a new variable and we'll create a material reference variable.
So material ref and this will be our material instance, which will be a sign in.
So let's just go ahead and change this to material.
And we'll just hit material there and then also object reference.
So that's our material.
And then we want to create a new variable and this will be display vehicle reference.
And if I spell vehicle correctly, vehicle compile and save just to make sure.
And then we'll do the display vehicle.
And you'll notice that we can get a reference to our blueprint here.
So display vehicle and that'll be an object reference.
Let's make sure we begin to categorize these because as you can see, there's a lot of variables going on now.
So you can actually select one, go to category and let's type in reference here.
So we've got a reference and then material reference.
We can now select it, drop down.
And from this drop down, you'll see references now an option.
So we've got our two reference variables.
Now let's create our three float values that we said we wanted.
So we've got temp UI, which again is a float value.
We've got airspeed UI.
Speed UI.
And then we've got our vehicle speed UI.
There we go.
Let's categorize these as well.
So let's call these user input.
So I do put a space on that category name as well.
Just so that's like that.
So we've got five variables created.
The categories don't so much matter as the material, the display vehicle.
Make sure these variables are the variable type.
And then we've got the three UI elements there.
So let's start off with the pre construct.
And so let's just right click, event, pre construct.
So we'll select that and we'll go to a sequence.
And a sequence essentially just fires a series of actions in order.
We'll go zero one and then you can add more to the pins if you want.
But for this purpose, we don't need that.
So I'm just going to compile, save.
And then we'll get the material image, dynamic material of the temp image
that we have.
So we have our temp image here, which is a variable that has previously
been created in the tutorial.
So we'll hold down Control and we'll get dynamic material from this.
And we'll drag that out there.
And then we'll set this as our material reference.
I'm going to hold down Shift and Alt, sorry, and drag.
Material instance.
Oh, so this is a dynamic material instance.
So I'm just going to delete this.
I'm going to compile, save.
And what we'll do is we'll change this from material to material instance.
So we need a material instance up there instead.
So let's go object type.
Let's see now hold down Alt and drag out there.
And that plugs in nicely to there.
So you just want to make sure you change that from material
instance.
Compile and save.
We'll just keep compiling and saving as we go.
And then next we want to get actor of class.
So get actor of class.
And we want to get the display vehicle from here.
Display vehicle.
And we can hold down Alt and drag and just drag that into there.
So something like that.
Compile, save.
Then we move on to the next section.
So we want to update the air speed based on the variable that we created before.
So let's right click, air spin.
Let's see, we want to get the value change on the air spin box.
So let's try air speed.
Let's do on value changed.
So let's get on value changed here.
So that's there.
So we'll get the air speed UI.
We'll drag out this holding down Alt.
Left mouse drag there.
And we'll get the, we'll set the air speed UI first of all based on that slider.
So that's correct.
And then we want to actually get the vehicle display reference from here.
So I'm just going to hold down control and get this.
Now you can actually right click these.
And if you just right click on the actual text, you can convert to a valid get.
Now, the reason why we do this is we want to make sure that this vehicle exists.
If for whatever reason you have this value on a slider and the vehicle does not exist
in the game, in the scene, sorry, the, it potentially just crashed the application.
So we want to, by getting a valid reference of the vehicle, it ensures that that vehicle does exist.
So we want to drag off the vehicle and we want to type in display and we want to set display air speed.
So we'll set this.
And this was a vehicle, a variable that we created on the vehicle previously.
So if it's valid, we want to set the variable and that can just be dragged in through there.
So that's essentially that.
We'll save, compile, move on to the next section.
Now we want to do the temperature slider because we create a temp UI slider there.
So let's get the temperature slider again.
Let's do on value changed.
So left click on value changed.
Now we, first of all, on the value change and we want to, like we did with the speed UI, let's do the temp UI.
So let's hold down alt, left mouse drag.
So we'll set that up like this.
And then we just want to make sure the temperature is set on the vehicle.
And that's the function that we created before.
So let's get a reference to the vehicle.
And now when we drag out the vehicle, we'll type in set temp.
And that's essentially the function that we created.
If you recall from the vehicle, we create this set temp function here.
And that's exactly what we're calling here.
So in a hood, we want to go back there and we just want to plug in that value there.
So we have something like that.
And then in the material reference, so we want to grab the material reference.
We want to set the scalar parameter value set.
Let's see.
Parameter.
Let's see what's available to us.
So we want to.
We definitely want to set a scalar parameter.
Let's see where that's at.
Let's just move on from that for a second, because we definitely want to set a material instance.
But let's just keep going with the set text of the actual UI.
So we want to find the text of the UI, which as we created before,
we've got the temperature here.
So we just want to make sure that this is a variable of some form.
And now we can go to the graph.
We want to then, was that the temp display?
Yep, temp display text.
So we've got that.
And then we want to set the text.
So set text.
We've got that.
And then to get the actual text, we want to, first of all, get the temperature UI, which
is the value that we've just created.
We want to get the mid-range.
There we go.
And we want to set that as 100.
And then we want to round up.
So we'll do seal.
And then we can actually then put that to the temperature.
So we can then go to format this text, format text.
Let's give ourselves a bit more space here.
Move this back.
So what we want to do is we essentially want to format the text like temperature.
So we have the temperature here, but we want to pull in this value.
So what you can do is you can do the squiggly brackets.
So hold down Shift and bracket on your keyboard.
So Shift bracket.
Let's do a temp like this.
And then because we got these two brackets, we now get temp here.
And then we can format the text like that.
And our two values on the range A are 60 and 95 there.
So that's essentially how we format the text.
Now we need to figure out how to actually set the scalar parameter value,
as that doesn't seem to be working correctly.
So let's just go ahead and maybe even create that material instance again.
So I'm just going to delete the material reference.
I'm going to delete this material reference.
And then I'll delete that material reference.
I'm going to compile and save.
And let's just try creating this material again.
So promote variable material inst ref, or something like this.
Let's try that.
I'm going to compile, save.
And let's see if this now updates.
I'm going to hold down Control off my new material ref.
Set scalar.
OK, so it's got a parameter value now.
So it must just be the way we'd created our material instance before.
So I've just created a new material reference.
Just dragging off here, promote to variable, call that a new variable.
We'll make sure we put it back into that references category as well.
So that's there.
And then we can just drag this out here.
So yeah, it must just have been the way we created our material instance.
So let's just slot that in there.
And then let's call that temperature, or whatever you named in the material,
temp.
So actually, let's call this temp.
So if you named yours temperature, call it temperature.
And in my temp, so we've got temp.
And then the value can just be the temp UI.
So let's get the temp UI again.
So I'm just going to copy and paste.
I'm going to divide this by 100.
So again, using that divide sign, or you can type in divide.
And then we'll again do this by 100 as we did before.
And then we'll clamp the flow.
So clamp float.
And then the min and max at 1 is fine.
So then we'll just do that.
So we want a value between 0 and 1 going out to the temp.
So we'll compile and save.
And that's the setup for the temp slider.
Let's just start commenting these.
I can select everything.
And we can hit C. And we can do temp slider functionality,
or whatever you want to call it, really.
But holding down C, pressing C, sorry,
when you have certain nodes selected,
let's say air speed functionality,
you can just comment things.
This is purely for aesthetic purposes
and organization purposes.
You can move the box around.
You can change the colors if you want.
Sometimes I like to drop the alpha a little bit just
to make that functionality stand out.
Whatever you'd like to do there, you can change the font size.
You can even copy the color and then paste the color
if you want.
Purely aesthetic reasons.
So that's that.
So I'm going to compile, save, move on to the next section.
And then the last variable that we've not used yet
is this car speed UI.
So let's go ahead and just add that.
So we essentially want the speed.
So the speed slider on value changed.
I think I might have already set this up previously.
But this is what you need here.
So let's just drag this down here.
I'll just recreate it so you know exactly what's going on.
Let me compile and save.
So car speed slider, we want the on value changed here.
And then we've just got the car speed UI holding down
Alt, left mouse dragging, just making sure all that's
plugged in like that.